une investiture par visio-conférence
crise sanitaire oblige la majorité
départementale ensemble pour les
Yvelines à dévoiler les 21 binômes en
lice pour les élections du 20 et 27 juin
prochain une présentation en présence
d'un soutien d'envergure le travail qui
est fait par le Conseil départemental
pour le territoire des Yvelines pour les
yvelinoises les Yvelinois pour les
communes des Yvelines est un travail de
qualité que ce soit dans le domaine
social dans le domaine de l'aménagement
des communes dans le domaine de la
voirie dans le domaine des collèges dans
ce mandat débuté en 2015 les binômes de
l'Union de la Droite de l'UMP est classé
divers droites avaient obtenu
respectivement 22 16 et 4 sièges une
assemblée sans opposition avec un
rassemblement de la droite et du centre
pour le prochain scrutin l'union sera
plus large ensemble pour les Yvelines
c'est le rassemblement c'est ce que
j'appelle le rassemblement du juste
milieu c'est-à-dire des gens modérés de
centre droit de centre gauche qui se
retrouvent là parce qu'ils sont d'accord
[Musique]
aussi avoir ce prisme là d'intervention
parmi les autres candidats on retrouve
car l'olive Catherine Arnoux Alexandra
Rosetti ou encore Olivier Lebrun qui
s'engage pour tenter de repartir pour un
nouveau mandat